it's great to be joined today by TJ Kirk
also known as the amazing atheist he has
been on YouTube since really some of the
early days of the site posting about
religion and politics social issues over
1 million subscribers not a frequent
interviewee TJ so I appreciate you
joining to me joining me today I know I
know you're not huge on being
interviewed yeah I get nervous and I
can't control everything so you know all
right well but uh thank you for uh thank
you for inviting me on I appreciate you
sharing your platform with me here today
we have an interesting robust discussion
yeah so I mean let's just start talking
about you my audience knows about
YouTube D monetization which hit us
starting May 31st 2017 a very important
day in David Pakman show history we've
since seen Twitter sort of involved in
what some are calling d platforming you
were banned from Twitter for some time
let's go back to the sort of beginning I
mean when when did you start
experiencing these sort of rough patches
in terms of your contents place on
YouTube and dealing with the D
monetization of individual videos there
was a time before the Big D monetization
thing where one of the one of the most
difficult things about YouTube to me is
their tendency to apply rules
retroactively Lee mm-hmm
so you know the TOS doesn't change it's
just the way it's enforced changes very
suddenly so like in the very early days
of YouTube there was a lot of drama
between people a lot of people fighting
one another you know making very brutal
attack videos against one another and it
still happens to some extent but there
was a time when it was kind of the bread
and butter of YouTube and then
retroactively like nope this is all
bullying now and then people who made
videos that here there too were
acceptable were being you know kicked
off the platform
so that was the first big indicator like
whoa this isn't just Mad Max free speech
zone and then there was YouTube did this
crack down on profanity probably around
like 2010 or something if you go back to
look at my videos around 2009 2010
you'll see that I believe my profanity
so there's that and then you know of
course the ad pocalypse which I know you
suffered from and every YouTube creator
I've talked to has suffered from yeah
yeah I mean I I have you know in the
context of what's been going on with you
and you know Alex Jones very notably
over the last couple of weeks I don't
have a problem with a private web site
having a privately owned web site rather
of course they are they're open to the
public in terms of accounts I don't have
a problem with Terms of Service I don't
have a problem with Terms of Service
being enforced what I think is sort of a
cop out is that most Terms of Service
include a provision along the lines of
you know this is all basically up to our
judgement and that's where this
selective enforcement group enforcement
where a bunch of platforms will decide
at the same time that they're gonna
target a specific type of content or
even a specific creator those are my
concerns like I don't really care about
Alex Jones as content per se I think
it's wacked out and I think if there's
anything illegal about what he's doing
it may be about how he's representing
some of those scam supplements but I'm
concerned with the selective and
subjective enforcement of the Terms of
Service are you do you agree or is your
concern a different one if I ever
decided to print out a copy of the Terms
of Service I'd probably do it on toilet
paper mm-hmm because that's the only use
I really have for it the Terms of
Service and Community Guidelines are
written to be vague enough that a huge
range of content can be you know
censored or permitted not based on rules
but strictly on the whims of the
platform you know these platforms don't
enforce rules they enforce a culture and
we've seen their double standards
manifest in does
the ways over the years like I don't
know how familiar are you with Kyle
kolinsky oh yeah yeah secular talk yeah
yeah I mean he had a resort to using you
know funny spellings of things with
weird accents over vowels and stuff that
didn't really apply just to try to get
around YouTube's language policing like
you know if I want to talk about
something going on in Syria I have to
make sure to spell it with a weird eye
that has three dots above it you know
but CNN can do that MSNBC can do that so
I mean you know the my problem with it
is the T my problem with all these TOS
is I guess is just there's they're not
applied consistently they never have
been
YouTube has gone through several
cultural shifts in terms of how it
police's itself since I've been here
about twelve years so I don't I don't
put item I don't care about the tos I
don't put much stock in the TOS because
it doesn't mean anything
it's just a bunch of words they just do
what they want when it comes to Twitter
your Twitter account of over a hundred
thousand followers was suspended about a
week and a half ago it's now reinstated
you sent out a satirical tweet can you
talk a little bit about what happened
and how it went down yeah there was
Sarah Zhong I think that's how her name
is pronounced I don't know how familiar
you are your audiences with the
situation but she she had a host of
tweets about white people you know I
enjoy when white people suffer because
whatever she's an Asian woman and she
was hired at the New York Times I forget
the position she was hired for but a lot
of people got upset I wasn't upset but I
found the situation amusing so I decided
to put out some sort of commentary on it
because it was a hot topic
I didn't take any sort of position one
way or the other but I just kind of
mocked the situation by I put my own
tweet out there that was an over-the-top
satirize ation of her Auntie white
people jokes or tweets you know I just
you know white people deserve to be
genocide at every last cracker one of
them should die some ridiculously
over-the-top thing and then at the end
of it I said hey New York Times how
about a lucrative job I think I've shown
the qualifications you know that was the
the little joke I made and I really I
tweeted it and I thought nothing of it
you were sort of I begin to question the
decision of the New York Times to hire
someone who had messages like that in
their in their internet history I don't
really think I was even doing that I
think I was just trying to
honestly ride the wave of people talking
about it I had no strong opinion one way
or the other I feel like if she wants to
make jokes about white people on Twitter
she can do that and if New York Times
wants the hirer they can do that I have
no objection to really any of that but I
just wanted to have some sort of generic
sort of commentary at least making fun
of to me the ludicrousness of the
situation not not from a I'm taking a
stance sort of position but just from a
isn't this funny and anyway they decided
that it was hate speech against white
people I guess you know I didn't feel
like it was I think most people who
looked at the tweet were like oh this is
satirizing the sarong situation I made
several appeals that were rejected to
Twitter it wasn't until people like um
Glenn Greenwald and Kyle kolinsky
started tweeting about it that Twitter
changed its mind and in your view other
people tweeting about it did get them to
change their mind I think especially
when Glenn Greenwald did I know that he
has connections with the higher echelons
of Twitter what do you think the policy
should be I mean there's
a spectrum when it comes to so-called
free speech and by free speech we don't
mean First Amendment as legally bound by
the Constitution we just mean the
plateau principle the principle of free
speech a popular spot people fall on is
if it's not illegal it should be allowed
where are you I don't know if you've
heard the talking point that's cropped
up recently about treating social media
platforms like pub you public utilities
and regulating them accordingly yeah I
mean not always I've read about that
there actually would be a legal
infrastructure dating back to the 60s
which would establish that it's just
it's not been done right that's been a
talking point of mine for at least five
years now and I I've been trying to
propagate it I've found practically no
ascents among friends among enemies
among anybody but in the wake of recent
events I've found a far more fertile
soil for that talking point and I've
heard it coming from prominent voices on
the left and the right my hope is that
maybe we're seeing the nascent stages of
sort of a bipartisan coalition for not
only the protection of free speech but
for the expansion of freedom speech so I
definitely think I brought my hat in
with the as long as it ain't illegal I
think you should be able to say it I
think that if a if a social media
platform reaches a certain level where
it becomes a tool of mass communication
then I think that there does need to be
some encroachment of free speech
protection into that platform because
otherwise we're censoring certain ideas
from what I consider to be a public
space be it privately owned or not so I
guess the idea would be if a platform is
so ubiquitous as a means of
communication and I think that the
president regularly using it to put out
what would have been deemed by courts to
count as presidential statements once it
has reached that level it's no longer
just a company saying we
allow some content we don't allow others
we have terms of service we might
enforce these selectively or not at all
or exactly by their letter there would
be some new standard with which they
would have to adhere to well look at
some point people are going to have to
decide what set of Rights matters more
the rights of a private company to
control their platforms or the rights of
the millions and millions in fact
billions sometimes of users of these
platforms to be able to have freedom of
expression and freedom of speech you
know this is a country that's founded on
that ideal I consider freedom of speech
to be the linchpin of our democracy so
are we going to allow that to in some
way die because you know the
conversation has moved on to these
platforms these are the public square
where people go and stand on the soapbox
and rant so if we're gonna say that we
allow you know private corporations to
control these things then we're
basically saying well private
corporations now control the discourse
in our country I'm not comfortable with
that I'm much more comfortable with
their rights as private companies being
infringed yeah and that is increasingly
the area of debate which is where does a
businesses I don't even really want to
call it right to self-determination but
right to make decisions that they
perceive as being the best business
decisions for them how far does it go
when these platforms do become sort of
clearing houses or
central squares as you mentioned I think
the good news at least in the short term
although it's not really a solution TJ
to what we're talking about is that you
are back on Twitter and over the long
term it's very clear that this is not
something that's gonna be solved quickly
and it's a debate that's gonna continue
yeah I agree
TJ Kirk known to many of you is the
amazing atheist you can find him on
YouTube he's then been there for a very
long time longer than the David Pakman
show and we've been there for quite a
long time as well TJ really appreciate
you talking to us today
thank you I appreciate you having me